foreign
today I just want to show people how to
get started
um making a basic shiny app and just
understanding the basic concepts
in order to do that we can just start
from the website this is the shiny for
python website
it's a shiny.rstudio.com pi I know that
might be really little in the browser
but uh we'll post a link for that and
the easiest way to get started just
working in code is just click on
examples all right and that will take
you to this website
shinylive.shinylife.io
where you can just you know you can just
work on your code here you can look at
the examples edit the code and run the
apps and this is one of the most
exciting things I think is that we can
you know you can use shiny
without having to install anything
without having to install uh even python
on your system you can just get in here
and start working right away
um and then you know as you develop an
app that becomes more sophisticated you
can work in a regular sort of a regular
python installation but to get started
this is a great way to do it
okay so let's take a look at this
example app there's a whole bunch of
different examples over here but by
default it just starts on this page and
to understand how a shiny application is
built there's two main components
there's the UI which is the part that's
displayed in the web browser this is a
web page that's displayed in the web
browser over here
and then there's the server logic
and this is python code that gets
executed when
somebody connects to this application
it executes this code once and then it
will re-execute
reactive functions in response to users
user input
so there's a UI here there's the server
code here and then that stuff gets put
together into a shiny app object over
here and so we're calling this app
object app which is that's what you have
to call it for this all to work
let's take a look at the UI so
in this case we have a input slider
which is this thing over here and then
output text verbatim so this is a text
output and the verbatim means that it's
printed as code with a monospace font
instead of being printed as normal uh
html text
and
as we change the slider
it causes this output to change
all right so
we got this this input in this output
component and they're wrapped up inside
of something called a page fluid now we
don't have to know the details about
this right now but for most applications
at this point we can just wrap these
components in a page fluid
all right so now what's connecting them
together is This Server logic here this
is a function it's called server and as
I said earlier it gets executed once
when the user connects to the
application
now there's a bunch of these decorators
here there's you know this is saying
we've got this thing that's an output uh
it's rendering text and then here we
have we're defining the function
um txt which returns a string so
now I'm going to change some of these
names just to make it a little easier to
explain things so let's say we'll call
this slider
um
my slider
and input
slider
and text
um you know I would call it txt
computation
all right let this
over here as well so I made some changes
to this application I'm just gonna I can
click this button to rerun it now it
looks the same
um but over here the variables should be
it'll be a little easier to see how
things line up
so
I've got the slider input and
it's the ID of it is my slider and then
I can read it in this function down here
so I can say input dot my slider
and I invoke that as a function and this
this function will return the current
value of the slider
and then what I'm taking what I'm doing
with that value is I'm putting into a
string
and this function text computation
um it takes this string and it's
sticking it into this output text
verbatim one of the cool things about
shiny is it's reactive Computing model
so if I move the slider I don't have to
do anything extra to tell it to
re-execute this function it just knows
like hey input my slider has changed so
re-execute this function every time I do
that
all right
now I can do some other things to this
like I can change this label here I can
say you know input a value
here and I can
because this is all running within the
web browser
python is running in the web browser and
shiny is running in the web browser I
can just click this button here and
re-execute uh re-execute this
application every time I make changes to
it so it makes it really easy to try out
new things
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]